Conquering fear in general,
right?
Right.
If you're a failure or a fear of rejection for the unknown,
um,
what would your advice be to someone who wants to start a business or a major
project?
But they're,
but they're held back by fear.
So
this is,
again,
it's interesting for me because public speaking is not something that induces
fear in me.
It never has a,
but I know that it does make people scared.
And I think that overcoming
the key day,
any overcoming any fear in my mind is,
we talked about this a little earlier,
which is inoculation and this idea,
and I actually looked up the definition of an occupation and it's the introduced
the introduction of a pathogen or antigen into a living organism to stimulate
the production of antibiotic antibodies.
So you're giving yourself a little bit,
right?
Right.
You give yourself a little bit and you build them off them and,
and that's what you do.
You take the small doses,
so it prepares you for the big,
bigger doses.
And I,
uh,
one of my daughters,
my middle daughter,
she was really wanting to be in the school play.
Right?
And other plays around town and oh you know,
okay cool.
Well that's cool.
But she was horrified to go out in front of an audience.
Horrified.
And so I looked up and I said,
okay,
well how do you stop your kids from being,
getting stagefright is the one they call it.
And you know,
I read about people,
what they did and what I did was I said I'd say,
okay,
a singer song for me.
And it's not that big of a deal cause I'm her dad as she'd sing a song for me.
And even then she'd be a little bit embarrassed,
but she'd sing a song for me.
And then,
you know,
a couple of days later I have my wife,
hey sing that song for both of us.
And then it was,
oh my wife's got a friend over,
hey sing that song for the three of us.
Cause how do you get a mystery person?
An unknown in the room.
Okay.
So she's overcoming that fear and each time she's getting a little bit more and
more confident because we took her to a,
what do they call tryouts?
What's to try out called audition,
audition.
We took her to a couple auditions where it was her turn and she didn't go.
She broke down just crying and just,
just,
just couldn't handle it.
And so then it was then it was a few of my wife's friends were over than it was.
Some of my friends were over [inaudible] now you've got,
you know,
guys and girls and each time she got more and more confident and eventually she
just didn't care anymore.
And she was totally confident and she got the lead role in the school plays.
She legitimately got the lead role in the school play.
So,
so she was able to overcome that fear.
And in the seal teams we do the same kind of thing.
We know where you're going to get inoculated against stress as much as they can
stress you out in the school,
thinks they're going to stress you out.
There's going to be machine gun fire,
you're going to be used to that.
There's gonna be explosions going off.
You're going to be used to that.
We used to do,
we used to do fly fire machine gun drills and,
and,
and I add drills,
immediate action drills.
We are maneuvering around.
We do that without ear PR,
ear protection and sometimes so you get used to this crazy banging.
We don't do that anymore cause it's not smart.
But uh,
but you do that to inoculate.
It's like what you were talking about earlier.
When that gun goes off you should be completely comfortable with it.
And there's an,
uh,
one of my favorite stories on that,
one of my favorite stories,
but one of them,
one of the,
uh,
a buddy of mine who actually took my job,
I was a task and your commander and he actually took my job as task and a
commander and a flash bang is a grenade that you throw into a room before you go
into the room and it makes a loud explosion and smoke and then it allows you to
enter in on the room when the people that are inside are now startled.
So you have an advantage.
Well,
occasionally,
you know,
you have to open the door to throw the crash in there and occasionally someone
will open the door and someone will run in by,
they didn't coordinate it well.
And so the open the door guy runs in and then someone throws the crash in.
So now you're crashing yourself.
It's not that big of a deal you got to use to it.
But what happened with one of his new guys,
you know that happened.
So the door went open,
the guy went in and I,
while the is running in,
somebody throws a crash in there,
the guy sees the crash and he runs back out of the room,
which is not what you're supposed to do.
So this guy was the task you to commander.
He goes,
Hey,
ah,
come with me and down here.
And so they walked down and he brought him into a closet in the kill house and
just sat in there and said,
yeah,
how's it going?
And they just sat there in the dark and dropped like eight crashes at their feet
and just blasted the guy.
Cause you realize that you just got to get an [inaudible].
You know,
you just got to overcome it.
So that's kind of,
I guess my,
my theory here would be if you're afraid of fighting and altercations,
go train Jujitsu.
If you're afraid of heights,
work on some rock climbing,
climbing.
If you're afraid of the water,
time to swim,
it's time to surf.
It's trying to get out there.
If you're afraid of pull ups,
if you pray to up to do pull ups,
if you're in squats,
do squats.
If you're afraid of public speaking,
go speak in public.
If you're afraid to start a business,
start a business,
make it small and on all these,
what you have to do is you have to mitigate the risk and you have to ease
yourself into it.
But you got to go for it.
And eventually you will overcome that fear.
But the hard part is you got to take that first step.
You got to take that first step to begin to inoculate yourself against the fear,
against the fear of the thing that's in your mind.
Cause that fear generally is in your mind that you know,
when you get up on stage,
do public speaking,
people are not going to throw tomatoes at you and say,
oh my,
you,
you're an idiot to get off the stage.
No,
they,
they're going to sit there,
you know?
So there's nothing to fear.
Yeah,
it's in,
it's in your head.